he's Justin Herbert he is the Oregon
Ducks quarterback and expected go pretty
high in the draft he joins us on the
program official height and weight
Justin it's eclipsed 6 to 36 now it's
not six five and a half and then you
rounded up in the program no it's
actually I think I grew a couple inches
from these past couple years so it's I
think it's official six okay because
there was a while there where we looked
at if you were sir if you were over six
five then we questioned that maybe you
were people were too tall to be a
quarterback have you heard that before I
actually haven't at one time but not too
often where are you going to be on
drafting I'll be in Eugene Oregon at my
house who else is going to be there my
family will be there and I think we've
got pretty strict rules about no more
than ten people here so I think maybe my
grandparents or we'll figure it out here
soon
you get takeout and then you have a
little bit of a celebration you don't
have to wait that long to hear your name
which is good
fingers crossed I what have you do can
you tell fact from fiction who's telling
you the truth like who really wants you
like it's trying to sort all this stuff
out is that's pretty heady stuff even
for grownups let alone a 22 year old
it's pretty tough and especially going
through this for the first time not it's
it's new territory for me so all of them
doing all I'm focusing on is doing my
best and getting better and whatever
happens happens I don't really have
control over the situation so just gonna
do my best and figure things out when
they come okay if I said right now your
best guess of who would be drafting you
sue I don't even know there's a field
just if just to feel you have it in your
head you probably go yeah I think they
like me a lot at this point I think it's
too tough to tell it's it's tough and
especially I've never really gone to
this this whole situation before so
that's tried to stay out of guesses and
these projections and things like that
so just focus on what I can't control
and that's my attitude and what I'm
doing
you know and stuff that's the right
answer by the way that's the right
answer yes because you don't want to say
you know what I think the Charger's
really love me and then all of a sudden
the Dolphins draft you or the other way
around you just you want to make sure
you stay neutral and I'll give you an A+
but by the way you won the William
Campbell Trophy
that's the academic Heisman I want to
know what the trophy looks like it uh it
looked like a guy punting the ball I see
holding a book or like I mean you got a
punting trophy yeah so he's got both
hands in the air just like he punted the
ball in one leg off and so did you even
know that there was a academic Heisman I
did actually I I think Chrisman Wilkins
one of the year before and so I I think
I kind of had an idea about it and some
people brought it up and said you know
it maybe you could win this so we can
add a singer's Crossan and unfortunate
that it worked out what's your major
it was biology but I switched it to
general science so this is more flexible
with my schedule
biology sounds a little tougher I get it
you wanted to ease up senior year mail
it in get some good grades win the
Heisman academic Heisman I'm right there
with you that's why I got into
communications was there ever a uniform
that you said I don't think this looks
good I would see me the duck we would in
2016 and we want wearing socks and I had
never really been a beaver fan I think
Warren kind of went against our color
schematic so I think that one was kind
of questionable but I guess people
really liked it it was thought it looked
good so I guess I didn't complain too
much yeah how did orange get in there
I think that's puddles our mascot is
feeder orange there are a lot of people
who did like that uniform but I kept
looking at the orange going Oregon and
Oregon State you can't have Oregon State
in there yeah
that's exactly what I thought - yeah
we're talking to Justin Herbert the
Oregon quarterback here where do you
work out now in my back yard actually so
I was always sent some dumbbells and
barbells and and we've got a lot of free
weights and I've got two brothers to
work out with me and there's a field
actually across the street that this
great big open field that we go throw at
and sometimes when we head up to this
little park and you can throw there up
there as well I'm kind of just figuring
things out us as best as we can you
could go to the stadium you're not that
far away couldn't you you got the keys
don't lock down access yeah so I
actually went there and I got kicked out
so haven't been a go back wait wait did
you say do you know who I am did you did
you have your Jersey on like I'm the
academic Heisman winner no I was just
doing with my brothers and they said you
know new rules in Oregon and I didn't I
didn't want to fight it so we took off
and went and worked out somewhere else
favorite team growing up was who in the
NFL it's kind of tough being from Eugene
you're no man's land aren't you yeah a
lot of West Coast team so it's you got
the 49ers the the Eagles are not the
Eagles but the Seahawks you had the
Raiders and a lot of these West Coast
team so I I don't know if I really had a
favorite I just kind of watching all the
games that that we could get over on
this house what about favorite
quarterback a lot of them I would say
Peyton Manning Tom Brady and then I
would say Marcus Mariota - just growing
up watching him especially since since
he went to Oregon as well and it weird
you'll be playing against Brady next
year it it's pretty surreal right
because then you've you can't fan boy
and like what do you do if at the end of
the game do you wait for him to come to
you or do you go to him if you guys face
each other I don't know that's I got I
got a lot of room to improve in before
there and a lot of places to go before I
get there so if it does happen like that
you know I'm sure it's about and angels
and what would you say I don't even know
what if whatever comes to my mind
good game and you might say mr. Brady
and then he would probably say call me
Tom and then you would say thank you and
he'll say hey good luck with your career
I'll play the role of Brady and you play
you okay now let me see you're gonna be
with the charge I'll put you with the
charge hypothetically with the Chargers
now I'm saying this not you
so here with two Chargers and I'm with
Tampa Bay I don't know if we play but
let's say game is over and we win in
overtime and you come in and you get
some playing time with Tyrod Taylor so I
go hey just want to say good luck with
your career and then you'll say okay and
then Tom's already gone so by the time
he says hey good luck and then when you
start to say what you're gonna say then
he just turns around and he probably
leaves but that's good that's it's the
way you got a hand you're ready to go I
mean I don't know how you're gonna field
but you're ready to go with answering
the questions here that's good stuff
here when you go through this process
and every year as many and I've been
doing this a long time and as many
prospects as I talked to it's hard to
read all of the criticism even if you
try to stay away from it if your mom or
your brothers or your you know
somebody's reading it and then they
might tell you how how does that
information get to you if you don't want
to know about it but you're still going
to hear about it yeah it's it's tough
yet that's six game and I think it comes
with the territory being a quarterback
and going through this process but if it
doesn't come from someone that directly
has an impact on me like a coach Chris
ball coach Arroyo or or even my parents
and I don't get too much credit to it
and I think that that's pretty important
because there's so much being said about
about everyone in any given moment you
gotta find out what's important and what
has value and what doesn't you except
the rating like that but when you're
called unfailingly polite how do you
respond to that I would say that if they
knew me I'm probably not too polite and
especially if you
my brothers and some of my friends they
probably tell you differently but that's
not a bad thing to be polite is it your
mom must go oh that's a wonderful thing
for you to hear I think she's probably
pretty proud of it um undergoing the
baling you know what do you what do you
use that first paycheck on is there any
big splurge here I'll probably save it
or help my parents out with with
whatever they need I've never really
been big into spending things and buying
things but I'll probably save it or help
them out well if they haven't paid off
the house I'd be a pretty cool thing
could be pretty hopeful oh yeah that's
where you know what you don't get them
anything until you can pay off the house
and then you just say hey by the way put
a big red bow in the house and you get
yours see I'm gonna help you out here
right I know you got agents so you got
people helping me helping you here but I
can help you I I am I can beat it up I'm
can be your sensei I can be your mr.
Miyagi and help you out with all of this
stuff because you're gonna need it
needed the first couple of years old
yeah pretty the thing that you do better
than the other quarterbacks in the draft
is what I think that's a tough question
I would say that I haven't spent enough
time and unfortunately not given enough
time every week to completely study the
other quarterbacks so I can't tell you
what I do exactly better than them today
and I haven't watched enough of them but
what I can tell you is what I think I do
well myself and I think I pride myself
on preparation and I really go into each
week and I know exactly what we're gonna
do and and gonna have a good shot at
what the opponent's gonna do and I think
arm strength is another thing that I've
got and I think that both those things
are pretty important to the quarterback
position
it's amazing that Joe burrow into and
Jordan level told me the things that
they do better than you they couldn't
wait so that's odd that you don't want
the performance in the Rose Bowl and
pretty emotional for you why do you
think it was so emotional when you know
at the end of that game I think from
going for an eight hour freshman year
and losing so many guys and going
through three head coaches was the same
group of guys that I came in with and
wanted to finish this year one of the
big reasons I decided to come back and
just to be there and be in the stadium
and just kind of have a couple months to
myself and kind of look around and
reflect I didn't think it got any better
than that and to be able to celebrate
with those guys with the teammates with
our coaches the city of Eugene and
misstate of Oregon present moment yeah
and you grow up not very far from campus
and you know you you have people in your
family tree who played there and then
you run for three touchdowns I mean a
pretty pretty emotional moment I could
imagine that but hey you're gonna have a
lot of moments ahead of you and we wish
you luck and certainly with that William
Campbell trophy you've already been a
big winner here the the academic Heisman
winner what more could you ask for thank
you yeah Justin thank you for joining us
and good luck on draft night appreciate
it thank you
that's Justin Herbert